انا موجود في متمه لا يفسرني عن قلابات
الحدود السودانيه
وهذا السور امامي يعني هذا النقطه التي
اقف فيها هي نقطه فاصله والمسافه بين
الحدود السودانيه قلابات ما هي عشره مترات
يعني يعني
الناس تتنقل من من خلفي من هذه النقطه
الحدود الاثيوبيه وامامي الحدود السودانيه
القادمين من السودان من قدارف لحد قلابات
تصل الى 500 دولار امريكي ويومين تسال من
20 الى 30 حافله الى هذا المنطقه ومن هنا
طبعا بعدما صارت ارتفاع الاسعار تدخلت
الحكومه الاثيوبيه امس وامرت النقل يكون
بالباسات التي تشاهدونها من خلفي
وحددت تسعيره 35 دولار طبعا قبل هذه
الاحداث كانت التذكره لا تتجاوز من خمسه
الى عشره دولار التدفق مستمر طبعا اليوم
وصلوا الى
نقطه الحدود بها السودانيه 1600 طبعا
عمليه نقل من قلابات للدزاوه اربعه ايام
لانه الحركه حدود 26
بااسا
يوميا ينقل مختلف وبالتالي عدد الناس
كثير طبعا
اليوم اول اليوم اول الواسعين اول
الواسرين
هم الرعايه المصريه عشر اسر وصلوا الى هنا
وبرضو يعني هناك اربعميه وثمانين طالب
صومالي وصلوا الى هذا النقطه وجنسيات
افريقيه
واخرى باكستانيه وهنديه